hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar ich q2 validation of analytical
procedures
for pharmaceutical total organic carbon
analyzers
i am michelle ashton of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by beckmann culture life sciences
to learn more visit beckman.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing this presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
we have several poll questions that will
be distributed through the web
throughout the webinar that will display
on your screen your participation is
greatly appreciated
i'd like to now welcome our speaker tony
harrison senior marketing manager at
bethmann culture life sciences
tony you may now begin your presentation
thank you very much for that
introduction and welcome everybody to
the niche today's short talk on total
organic carbon analysis for the
pharmaceutical quality control
laboratory and how it relates to ich q2
my name is tony harrison i'm a senior
manager at beckmann cultural life
sciences and i will be your presenter
today
throughout this presentation i'll be
abbreviating the total orgasm organic
carbon sorry to toc
so whilst this presentation is based
around ich q2 and toc
i've also included a little content
around improving data integrity because
i know it's such a hot topic for us in
our industry in the pharmaceutical
industry today
now in that 2018 um
questions and answers document that the
fda published on 21 cfr part 11 data
integrity
they voiced their concern that they had
increasingly observed cgmp violations
involving data integrity during their
inspections
and for the first time they introduced
the acronym alcoa
i'm sure familiar to many of you but
it's used to describe what good data
integrity looks like
and the last a in the acronym alcoa
stands for accuracy of the records data
and what they're saying there is they're
indicating that security and safety of
the electronic record is important but
um
it's not the only focus of 21 cfr part
11.
it's also important the electronic
record has accurate information or data
in it
and here they're suggesting that
anything
that contributes to improving the
accuracy of an electronic record is a
positive thing
they always encourage
the use of latest technology such as
automation of the sops which tends to
reduce the impacts of human error
now the qbd 1200 toc analyzer from
beckmann quarter is designed to suit the
pharmaceutical qc application
it can analyze toc levels from 0.4 ppe
2 to 100 000 ppb or 100 ppm
it uses the industry standard
combination of a uv light ultraviolet
light and for sulfate method
and its auto sampler can take up to 64
vials at a time
the user can program and automate their
sops into the qbd 1200 which allows the
operator to simply select the correct
sop for their testing using an intuitive
icon driven menu
so let's take a look at how the qbd 1200
analyzes
toc in the first step of the analysis
the qbd acidifies the water sample being
analyzed to encourage any total
inorganic carbon or tic
that's present in the sample to come out
of solution now the pharmacopoeias point
out to us that tic or totally organic
carbon tends to be in pharmaceutical
grade waters with purified water and
water for injections primarily made up
of dissolved carbon dioxide gas
so after acidification a carrier gas is
used to purge the tic outer solution
when through to a non-dispersive
infrared detector where it's measured
and the total tic is then reported
in the second step of the toc analysis a
strong ultraviolet light is turned on to
release the carbon atoms in the organic
material present in the sample
the organic material is oxidized by
hydroxyl radicals which are created by
the effect or the impact of the uv light
on the water molecules themselves
plus then the uv light also combined
with the sulfate
um it acts on activated saltwater
and the toc is reduced released from the
organic
co2 gas
it's important to note that sulfate
doesn't actually act as an oxidizer
until exposed to the uv light
in the third analysis step the carrier
gas is used to sweep the co2 from the
oxidized toc
out of solution and it is then measured
by the non-dispersive infrared detector
now as i mentioned a few moments ago
in their 2018 questions and answers
documents on 21 cfr class 11 data
integrity
the fda voiced their concern that they
were increasingly observing gnp
violations in evolving data integrity
during their inspection
and
they indicated while the security of the
final electronic record is important and
it should be protected against
adulteration it's not the only focus of
21 cfr apart 11 but also that the
electronic record contains accurate data
too
now they introduced the uh acronym alcoa
in their 2018 guidance and it stands for
attributable legible
contemporaneous and original and the
last a in the acronym starts for active
stands for accuracy with the electronic
records data
and as i say here they're saying
anything that
contributes towards improving the
accuracy of the electronic record the
data it contains is a positive
such as automating sops
now a 2016 report
states that 79 of all of the warning
letters written by the fda their 483
letters in that year cited 21 cfr r7
data integrity issues so 79 of the
letters
and whilst retraining
is a common response to an fda 483
warning letter
this may be only part of the solution
was the problem simply that the workers
didn't follow the sop correctly or
was it really that manual sops are
simply not robust enough to prevent
future recurrence of the problem
now any process that automates the
quality control sop can potentially both
reduce the impact of human error on data
integrity issues and also brings welcome
savings by reducing the time technicians
need to use to devote to carrying out
the sop itself
now here's an example where manual saps
can lead to error and inaccurate records
it's some commonly used qc lab toc
analyzers using carbon dioxide permeable
membranes as part of the measurement
process
the users the technicians have to guess
how much oxidizing for sulfate to add
in other words they need to know the
left the to level of toc present in the
sample before they carry out the test
so how can they know this
so the problem is if they add too much
basalt rate
you know more than is required for the
level of toc presence you can get
bubbles forming on the in the analysis
chamber and they block these permeable
membranes that are used in some
analyzers
and this causes the analyzer to under
report because the carbon dioxide can't
get through the membrane to be measured
equally however they don't add enough
basalt rate for the level of toc
presence in the water sample
toc will not be fully oxidized and again
the toc analyzer will bring the report
now the qbd 1200 from beckman is not
affected by balls in the sample
and as a minimum by standard defaults
the qbd 1200 adds sufficient facilitate
oxidizer to each
sample to safely oxidize up to 4 000 ppb
of toc
so this ensures that toc results are not
under reported in normal water samples
like purified water water injection
all toc analysis sops can be
pre-configured and programmed into the
qbe 1200 so the technician has reduced
manual configuration steps which helps
to reduce the opportunity for human
error which of course could affect the
accuracy of the data in the electronic
record itself
so let's now move on to ich q2 in the
second part of our presentation today
the primary purpose of the tripartite
international conference on
harmonization ich
their committee is the primary purpose
is to harmonize the japanese united
states and the european foreign peers
however they also perform other
functions such as producing guidance
such as the ich q2 document which is
about validating instruments to short
but to make sure they're fixed of
purpose
there's an iq oq and pcu documented
procedure available for the qbd 1200 and
the iqoq sections of course confirm that
the analyzer is installed and performing
as intended but the pq section carries
out the required testing to validate the
analyzer
to the qbd to ich qbd sorry i've got a
q2 guideline
the ich q2 document provides a
discussion of the characteristics for
consideration during the validation of
an analytical procedure
including those listed on the slide
so let's take a look at each of these
attributes in detail and how the p2
computing 1200 demonstrates compliance
ich q2 suggests that an instrument's
accuracy can be demonstrated by
examining examining the instrument's
response to a certified reference
standard so a certified traceable
reference standard
the qbd 1200 pq uses a certified
potassium hydrogen phthalate solution
containing 5 000 ppv or 5 ppm of toc
automated on-board dilution allows
comparison against this standard at five
points across across the measurement
range
that's usually the sop is preloaded and
automated and it's selected from an icon
on the screen so there's no manual
configuration
no manual pass fail so it reduces the
opportunity for human error
now although
the united states and the european
pharmacy is do not specify
the calibration solution to be used on
toc analyzers but the japanese
pharmacopoeia does it calls for khp to
be used
and hence by using khp the qbd 1200 can
be seen to comply with all three
pharmacopoeias
the qbd 1200 accuracy is demonstrated by
comparing its response to five different
levels of coc
and the pass fail calculation is
automated so no manual
calculations of the pass fail and this
avoids done
and reduces human error
our ich q2 goes on to suggest that
precision of an analyzer can be assessed
by comparing multiple
analyses of the same example
it recommends three replicas of three
concentrations of toc are used and the
pq for the qbd 1200 follows this
guidance by doing three replicates each
of one two three four and five ppm or
5000 ppb of toc
the performance of the qvd 1200 against
this precision test is calculated
automatically providing the real results
of a standard deviation calculation
now in this slide we are explaining the
difference between accuracy and
precision i'm sure
most of you are familiar with this but
um the first start board in the top left
there shows
um
what happens when you have neither
accuracy nor precision so all the hits
on the dart board all over the place
the second dartboard on the top right
shows excellent precision
with very repeatable results but it's
nowhere near the bull's-eye so it's got
poor accuracy
now a third dartboard shows relatively
good accuracy with the results clustered
around the bullseye but the precision or
repeatability of the testing is poor as
the results are not consistent
and finally the fourth dartboard shows
us what both good accuracy and high
position combined together looks like
with the results repeatable and on
target
now specificity tests listed in ich q2
demonstrates that the toc analyzer can
measure and report toc accurately both
on over the range of expected toc
substances to be found in in typical
pharmaceutical waters and also in the
presence of potentially interfering
substances that may be in the sample
compliance with the first part is
demonstrated by carrying out the system
suitability test to ensure that the toc
analyzer can successfully analyze
the full range of organic materials
expected to be present in pharmaceutical
grade waters
the ability to successfully measure the
presence of inside measured toc in the
presence of large amounts of potentially
interfering inorganic carbon or tic
it's demonstrated by challenging the
alloys with two samples
one they both contain the same amount of
organic carbon but one of them contains
large amounts of inorganic carbon in the
form of dissolved co2 which is typically
how he's finding pure dried water
so if the analyzer can report the same
toc results from both samples that is
deemed to have passed successfully
the qbd 1200 can handle very high levels
of tic because it completely sparges it
or push it out from the sample before
attempting to measure toc
once the tic is sparged from the sample
the uv lamp is turned on and the
analysis of toc
commences
the qbd therefore take makes the direct
measurement of toc not a calculated one
so it actually measures toc directly not
calculating it and so the plus or minus
two percent tolerance on the sensor that
the qbd uses
means for example as there might be
potentially a plus or minus two parts
per billion potential error
in a sample containing 100 ppb of toc
and this is despite the presence of
relatively large amounts of gic
now the limit of detection is the
smallest amount of a substance the
analyzer can detect
but not necessarily accurately report
whereas the limit of quantitation is the
smallest amount of a substance that
analyzer will not only detect with our
accurate accurately measure and report
and neither of these of course is very
easy to do in the real world especially
with um a limited detection of 0.4 ppb
so what ith q2 does it provides guidance
on how to calculate the limited
detection and limited quantitation based
on the standard deviation of the results
from a calibration
now the linearity
linearity test defined in ich q2
determines the ability of an analyzer to
report accurately over a range of
analysis
and the performance qualification for
the qed shows this by um across a range
of measurements
so the linearity
as the pass fail calculations automate
it and again avoids manual calculations
and the range of the qbd 1200 is
demonstrated by testing in the
measurement range and then explaining
that the higher levels of toc are
analyzed
to automatic sample dilution using a
calibrated syringe pump actually it's
plus one percent so in the case of toc
one part per billion is equivalent to
one
microgram
per liter of water and of course the
liter of water is a kilogram if it's
pure water weighs a kilogram
so it's important to understand because
one liter samples containing say 100 000
parts for building a toc
which is hundred micrograms per liter if
that's then diluted by another liter of
toc free water so water with no toc in
it
but toc level and the resulting two
liters of water is halved
and is now just five thousand
fifty thousand ppb
so if you dilute the water sample under
test you reduce the ppv levels of toc
present
by employing this dilution technique the
qbd can dilute and analyze water samples
containing up to 100 000 ppv of toc even
though the actual measurement range of
the non-dispersive infrared detector is
only 5 000 ppp
i.e the qbd dilutes the sample by a
factor of 20 and of course 20 times 5
000 gives you the hundred thousand
in samples up to 4000 ppb
toc sample dilution is not required as
the amount of basal plate added
automatically each time by the qvd will
successfully analyze this level of toc
above this level the qed automatically
determines the amount of crossover to
add and so the user does not need to
guess
so this is one of our first poll
questions
so
we now move on to robustness now
robustness according to ich q2 is the
ability to measure successfully despite
variations in the sample characteristics
now as the qed adds acid to the sample
to encourage the co2 to come out of
solution and be measured
of the gas in theory the ph of the
sample might impact on the measurement
however as part of the performance
qualification demonstrates this is not
the case by deliberately testing the qbd
with samples of toc where the ph has
deliberately been altered showing that
the measurement performance of the qbb
is not affected by
shifts in the
ph
that's our next poll question
okay
moving on to intermediate precision
now this is an interesting one and it's
really um
looks at the effects of random events on
the precision of the analytical
procedure itself
so it's it's looking at typical things
to study such as time of day temperature
but also the technician or analysts who
are using the toc analyzer as well
so the way we demonstrate this with the
pq is that we automate the ssd so the
instruments automatically configured the
same way
every time
and also we automate the addition of
sulfate to ensure the toc is analyzed
correctly so we don't need technicians
who can guess how much toc
is in the sample and therefore how much
for sulfate to add it's all automated
and finally the performance
qualification demonstrates its
robustness by
being unaffected by gas bubbles in the
sample because the ndidr detector
is selective to only measures carbon
dioxide
the standard amount of sulfate added
covers even the widest range of toc
analysis analysis
required in a pharmaceutical grade water
system
so that concludes our short presentation
today i hope you found it
informative i'll now take any questions
the audience has please
well thank you tony for your informative
presentation we will now go ahead and
start the q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for so let's go ahead and get
started our first question
you mentioned 21 cfr part 11 data
integrity could you please explain again
how many error can lead to data
integrity challenges
for sure definitely so yeah human error
if it creeps in in the test in the
configuration of the instrumentation um
it can cause problems with data
integrity now in that fda's alcoa
acronym as i mentioned in the
presentation the final a in the alpine
acronym refers to the accuracy of the
electronic record itself so we're not
talking about security or or
anything like that it's really about the
data in the electronic record
so human error and toc analyze
configuration
and lead to errors in the analyzer
results
so the electronic record itself although
secure
is not accurate it doesn't represent an
accurate analysis so i gave an example
how hugh and eric can creep into toc
measurements just now
when i explained how users of some
typical toc analysts have to guess the
amount of toc in the water sample in
order to dose the correct amount of
sulfate
so
the temptation is not to put too much
sulfate in because that runs the risk of
creating bubbles and under reporting the
toc in the sample but that potentially
leads to accuracy issues in the
electronic record unfortunately the qbd
measurement is not affected by this
problem
thank you tony our next question
you mentioned that with some toc
analyzers the technician has to guess
how much of oxidizer
the personal fate to add to the sample
based on a guess of the toc content in
the sample
but how can they guess the toc content
before they make a measurement
that that's exactly the point really
it's kind of a chicken and egg thing if
you excuse the analogy because you have
to know
how much toc is in the sample
to add the sulfate to then measure the
toc so it's a challenge
and it faces many technicians using toc
analyzers today but unlike some commonly
used qc lab toc analyzers that measure
tiers to measure organic carbon sorry
dissolved in the water sample using
permeable membranes
as part of the measurement process which
is what caused which is what causes the
issues with sulfate the qbd 1200
measures carbon dioxide from the organic
carbon in gas phase it doesn't use
permeable membranes so the presence of
gas bubbles does not interfere with the
measurement
hence when we're measuring whether we're
measuring
purified water or water rejection we can
safely add up the sulfate every time
to analyze up to 4000 ppp of toc without
interfering with the measurements in any
way at all
and of course as toc is a limit test
with the maximum limit being 500 parts
per billion the ability to oxidize
oxidized to 4000 ppb ensures that any
excursions above the 500 ppb limit would
be captured and reported
thank you tony we have one more question
here for you
thank you for your presentation it is
well known that some laboratory toc
analyzers measure both inorganic carbon
and total carbon using separate sensors
and then use these two measurements to
calculate
toc frequently resulting in errors in
the reported toc value
even sometimes reporting negative toc
results due to sensor drift could you
please explain how the qbd 1200 avoids
these types of errors
uh thank you that's a good question
and i think that the basic is that
unlike some
laboratory toc analyzers the qbd 1200
removes the inorganic carbon from the
sample first and measures that
directly
and then oxidizes the toc and measures
the carbon dioxide from that
so it's directly making a measurement of
toc using a single sensor which has an
accuracy of plus or minus two percent so
because it's using the single centering
tooth instead of two different sensors
it's not possible for the qed 1200 to
report a negative to
toc result because it measures toc
directly rather than calculating it from
two separate measurements
well thank you tony do you have any
final comments for our audience before
we close today
no just thank you very much for your
attending and listening to my
presentation i hope you thought it was
useful and um yeah enjoy the rest of
your day
thank you again tony for your time today
we would also like to thank labroots and
our sponsor beckman colter life sciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
reminder questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues or anyone who may
have missed today's event until next
time
goodbye